alo alo
ồ Alo thế nơ bé nhở
Alo Ok Ờ Xin chào
bạn Ừ đợi tí Hình như là tôi cần xóa bớt
Hôm trước có tâm sự một vài cái
ồ có vài bạn hôm trước hỏi này để tôi
ngồi tranh
thủ trình lại cái này
đ thì đợi tôi một
sẻ được cho bạn
tuổi trẻ đáng bao
câu khá là hay kiểu
sẽ khá là rất là đáng giá gọn như nào
nhỉ chúng ta thường hay trân trọng những
cái gì mà chúng ta bỏ lỡ hoặc chiến giả
chưa có đấy
thì với một vài người thì nó sẽ rất là
có giá trị thậm chí là vô giá các thứ
các thứ nhưng mà về đa số anh em mình
Bây giờ thì ừ thì nó cũng rất là có giá
đấy nhưng mà quan trọng là cái giá đấy
nó mình tận dụng được bao nhiêu đúng
không đầu tiên thì phải hỏi phải quay
ngược lại là tại sao nó lại lại có giá
bởi vì là tuổi trẻ mình sẽ có thời gian
và sức khỏe đúng không thường là sẽ có
thường mọi người thường anay nói thế
Mình có cơ hội để làm lại rất nhiều cái
đấy Đấy là một trong những cái mà ít
người nói
đấy Mình có cơ hội mình hoàn toàn có thể
cơ hội để mà thử đủ mọi thứ ông ví dụ
Giả sử ông làm một cái gì thất bại bây
giờ Ok ông vẫn thể làm lại Bởi vì ít ra
nó không ảnh hưởng đến rất nhiều người
nó không ảnh hưởng đến ví dụ Giả sử là
không gì đó quá Trâm trọng và mọi người
đi khi còn châm trước cho ông là kiểu
tuổi trẻ ai có sai lầm Ai có tuổi trẻ
vân vân đấy chứ Bây giờ giả sử ông lớn
Già đầu rồi đấy ông tầm 30 40 có gia
đình rồi lúc đấy ông mới có những cái
sai lầm mà kiểu bởi vì hồi bé hồi trước
ông chưa chải ông chưa thử Bây giờ ông
bây ông bộc lộ ra cái điểm đấy xong rồi
người khác kiểu lên án lên tiếng đấy lúc
đấy người ta sẽ bảo kiểu lớn tướng tuổi
đầu rồi đấy có gia đình rồi có con cái
rồi Tại sao phát ngôn như thế vân vân Ui
lúc đấy thì ông ấy biết được là kiểu do
tuổi trẻ mình chưa trải sự đời đúng
không Thế nên là thế nên là kiểu lúc mà
về già thì
mình mình đôi khi là mình sẽ cũng có cái
tôi rồi bảo thủ một tí cũng đúng đấy bởi
vì lúc đấy mình ngại thay đổi ngại va
chạm sợ động đâu hỏng đấy thôi Thì nó
đang yên ổn rồi hãy để nguyên nó thế
đấy Tôi không biết ông mấy ông đã từng
nghe cái đấy chưa Nhưng mà chắc chắn cái
câu là tuổi
trẻ kiểu Tuổi Thanh Xuân Vân Vân Vân
nghe nó rất là xa nghe nó rất là vô giá
các các thứ nhưng mà chưa ai chắc là tôi
thấy ít người nói về vấn đề đấy là việc
là mình
mình phải thử phải trải nghiệm như này
thường là cù lắm là nhiều người dạ nh
nhiều tỷ phú thì nói là kiểu tuổi trẻ có
thể kiểu phá sả Xong rồi xong
rồi ngã ở đâu đứng dậy ở đấy ngã ở đâu
gấp đôi ở đấy đấy nhiều người mới chỉ
nói dừng về mỗi đầu tư thôi chứ không hề
nói việc là trải đời các thứ
thứ ở công ty ngoài code back end ra anh
phải code những gì thực tế là tôi ở công
ty tôi kiểu cũng cũng có bởi vì tôi
không chuyên về mảng giáo diện lắm Tuy
là biết code JavaScript nhưng mà Mấy ông
tự đánh giá tự thấy lúc mà tôi ngồi code
thì à Thì tôi thấy thấy tôi cách tôi mà
làm việc V kiểu ngồi làm ra scrip nó
cũng kiểu ngồi mò mò mò các thứ thứ nó
nó không nhanh bằng hồi làm lúc mà làm
backend thì các bạn sẽ tự đánh giá được
à Ví dụ ví dụ một điển hình thôi đó Hôm
nay xếp Tôi vừa giao tôi một cái tas rồi
bảo là hôm nay thứ năm thì hiy vọng là
thứ năm tuần sau là xong đấy Thế mà hôm
nay tôi gần như là xong rồi Hôm nay tôi
báo với xếp Chính xác là tôi làm cái đấy
trong kả 4 tiếng bởi vì sáng nay tôi xin
kiểu làm on ch Chiều nay tôi đến với bàn
giao công việc đấy đấy 4 tiếng tôi đã
gần như xong rồi đấy back end tôi tự tin
là tôi làm khá là nhanh và khá là kiểu
mình à Mình biết mình phải làm gì đấy
nên mình cứ nghĩ cắm độ và làm và thời
gian trôi qua nhanh thật đấy còn fen thì
th ra cũng đấy chỉ biết ra scrip các thứ
thứ chứ còn thực ra là đương nhiên là có
bú chat rồi không cần phải quan tâm lắm
Về cái giao diện lắm nhưng mà Đúng là
mình yếu về khoản CS kiểu mình không
biết nhiều hàm các thứ tiếp theo về về
cái gì
nhỉ và đặc biệt là tôi làm việc với cơ
sở liệu về api khá là nhiều nghĩa là
kiểu tích hợp api kết hợp
với làm kiểu tối ưu câu truy vấn thống
kê các thứ hôm nay vừa ngồi sửa cái
thống kê xong đấy thì thì tối ưu một cái
dự án đôi khi nó liên quan đến tối ưu
câu truy vấn thôi nên là tôi sẽ kiêm
luôn cả việc tối ưu các thứ còn về cái
Factor code thì chắc là tôi chỉ sửa lại
để cho nó tối ưu Chứ tôi cũng khó mà
kiểu đủ chuyên để mà làm kiểu refactor
code lại cho nó trong chuyên nghiệp hay
là clean code thì vẫn chưa đủ giỏi đến
tầm
mà linh hoạt
đúng nhưng mà Đấy là tùy theo mô hình
công ty Ví dụ công ty tôi là công ty
startup thì tính ra là anh anh em mà
full stack được thì rất tốt V rất tiện
bởi vì sẽ ôm luôn toàn bộ công việc đấy
đảm nhiệm luôn một cái kiểu một cái tính
năng đấy chứ không phải là lúc mà lúc mà
có vấn đề thì không biết trách ai đúng
không ạ Còn C còn nếu là môi trường theo
kiểu là doanh nghiệp các thứ một cái
công ty tập đoàn lớn thì chắc chắn là
các bạn sẽ chỉ ôm một phần và các bạn
làm nó không còn hoàn toàn là công ty kể
cả cho D công ty product nhưng không ho
toàn giống prod nữa mà ông sẽ được giao
tát làm hết tá này giao tát khác các thứ
thứ nó hơi công nghiệp nó giống như là
công ty ao xộc đấy Ông cứ làm xong phần
của ông xong cứ bàn dao bàn dao đấy Xong
rồi ông lại được đẩy lại vào làm cái
phần khác mảng
khác chứ nó không có quay đi quay lại
làm một vài cái và kiểu nâng cấp cải
thiện lên một vài
Anh học lập trình từ bao giờ với anh học
tiếng Anh như thế nào ạ Tôi học lập
trình để mà nói chính xác hồi đầu tiên
học lập trình thì chắc chắn là học bcan
hồi cấp hai đấy tôi Hồi đấy tôi cũng có
làm một vài bài tập kiểu thay cho cả lớp
bởi vì mấy ông biết kiểu có một ông kiểu
trong phòng tin đặp biệ gi tin ấ ngồi
làm rồi xong rồi làm chia sẻ cả lớp và
cả lớp ngồi chơi ấ tôi cái thằng kiểu
như
thế Hồi đấy Không hẳn là giỏi giang gì
đâu Chỉ đơn giản là mình không lại lẫm
mình mới tính còn các bạn kia thì kiểu
lần đầu động máy tính mà nên các bạn ấy
còn đang bững ngỡ mình đã gõ nhanh hơn
các bạn đã một lợi thế rồi
đấy nhưng mà hồi đấy thực ra không hề
đam mê lập trình đâu
nhá Bởi vì kiểu chỉ làm nhanh thì còn
ngồi chơi thôi cũng chẳng nghĩ gì nhiều
cả
thì phải lên tôi lên đại học này lên
không Thực ra tôi chưa đại học quên mất
tôi lên trường Nghề này thì năm hai bọn
tôi học được chuyên ngành thì lúc đấy m
thực sự là Tôi động vào lập trình nên là
không hẳn là lập trình sớm như như nhiều
anh em Bây giờ nhiều anh em bây giờ kiểu
đã định hướng nề nghiệp trước thì sớm
nhưng mà cũng mông lung
sớm kiểu thế tôi thì có tuổi thơ cũng
kiểu kiểu dạng được chơi các thứ thứ chứ
không Không phải kiểu cắm đầu vào học
đâu Anh học tiếng Anh như thế nào ạ
Không thực ra tôi nói nhiều về mấy ông
về vấn đề về liên quan đến tiếng Anh rồi
đó là kiểu tại sao cái này cứ tăng lên
nhỉ Có trang này có á Gì à Tại sao cứ
tăng lên đấy Ờ gì nhỉ
Ừ thì theo tôi học học một cái gì đó
chăng nữa bất kỳ cái gì ông vẫn sẽ có
phải
độ nói chung là không hẳn là đam mê đâu
nhưng ít nhất ông phải quen dần với nó
và thích nó đã ông đừng có suy nghĩ việc
là mình đang học một cái gì đó ví dụ Giả
sử là tôi xem phim ông Mỹ Tôi thích kiểu
đấy xem ngay từ bé này ngay nhạc ông Mỹ
từ bé này Đấy đương nhiên là phát âm
tiếng Anh của tôi vẫn còn không chuẩn nó
lắm vì kiểu kiểu mình không thực hành
nhiều nhưng mà mình nghe ít nhất là mình
nghe ổ nó n ná giống như là đứa trẻ con
ấy đứa trẻ con Thực ra hồi bé nó chỉ học
nghe trước học nghe cái đầu tiên nó học
đúng không ạ Đấy xong rồi cò Viết thì
được viết về ngữ pháp của tôi 50 50 lắm
cũng cũng kiểu học xong lại quên mà
nhưng mà nói chung là bởi vì mình nghe
nhiều nên mình nhớ đấy Kiểu nghe xong
mình nghe nhiều nên nhớ câu kiểu có vần
vần như thế này thì mình sẽ viết vào Nói
chung là hồi hồi cấp hai tôi còn tương
đối học được tốt tiếng Anh Một kích
tương đối xong nhưng mà hồi lên cấp ba
thì gặp phải cô giáo tiếng Anh kiểu cũng
có rất nhiều vấn đề mà tôi không đi học
thêm cô đấy nên cô rất vui dập nên thành
ra kiểu Hồi đấy tôi đã ghét tiếng Anh
nhưng mà đương nhiên là không Tôi biết
được tiếng Anh quan trọng đên về sau tôi
vẫn vẫn đi học giao sư xong rồi có chị
giao sư đầu tiên chị ấy rất là xinh nữa
đấy Nên là chị tạo động lực truyền cảm
hứng rất nhiều cho mình để mình kiểu
Thực ra là gọi là học tiếng Anh nhưng mà
thực ra là kiểu những buổi giao sư chị
đấy tôi toàn ngồi nói chuyện với chị đấy
chém gió nhưng mà đương nhiên bằng tiếng
Anh đấy để cải thiện các thứ thứ cả ngồi
làm bài tập để chỉ ngồi ngồi xem thôi
Nói chung là lúc đấy tôi lấy lại được
động lực kiểu nói chung là ổn hơn các
thứ các
thứ nhưng mà bây giờ đi làm ấy Thực ra
thì ờ cũng đương nhiên là động vào tiếng
Anh thì có bởi vì tài liệu các thứ thứ
mà xong rồi làm việc với công ty nước
ngoài nữa tôi không hể thấy lấn cấn một
cái gì cả có rất nhiều cái nhiều lúc mà
mình không biết từ mới thì tôi có tiện
ích để cha để mà ấn vào cái là nó tự
động dịch rồi Hoặc là lúc mà viết lúc mà
viết văn bản bằng tiếng Anh thì tôi toàn
dùng ai để mà hỗ trợ kiểu sửa lại về C
pháp cả chỉnh mấy cái từ kiểu mấy cái từ
mình dùng toàn mấy từ phổ thông thì nó
phải
dịch lại phiên dịch Lại
sang kiểu mấy cái từ thuật ngữ chuyên
ngành ấy cho nó ngầu hơn các thứ thứ Đấy
thế là xong Nói chung là tôi cảm thấy là
A bây giờ hỗ trợ rất là nhiều để mà kiểu
mình tiện hơn trong việc
kiểu nói chung là mình tiện hơn trong
việc kiểu làm các thứ
thứ còn đọc tài liệu Nói chung là tôi
kiểu quen từ khóa là đọc thôi không hề
khó khăn gì
không
anh công ty startup thì đúng Em sẽ phải
ôm từ đầu đến cuối làm cái gì đó ch
thường Thiếu người mà em tính đầu tháng
7 đi phỏng vấn thử fesser Junior thì có
cần ôn thật toàn không Anh hãy ôn chắc
op ngại phần thật toán á Thật toán thực
ra là code để rèn tư duy thôi Thực tế là
là kiểu ở công ty tôi có nói Hằng công
ty tôi ít người dành th toán lắm nên tôi
cũng gọi là biết được vài cái cơ bản
giống như là kiểu chạy phòng lặp để gán
cờ hay các thứ thứ mấy cái kiểu đơn giản
thôi đương nhiên là nếu mà mình biết thì
về sau mình kiểu làm công việc thỉnh
thoảng mình biết cách làm thì thì tôi đã
thấy kiểu nhiều Ông ở trên công ty kiểu
viết mấy cái đoạn code trông rất là phức
tạp Bởi vì ông ấy không D dành Chu toán
thận thế thành ra là kiểu rõ ràng là nó
có cách để mà nó chạy ít vòng lặp hơn nó
đơn giản hơn độ phức tạp nó dễ hơn này
nế ông ấy không hề biết thì đấy Đấy là
một cái trường hợp điển hình ấy nếu mà
về sau ông ông mà kiểu biết một tí th
toàn biết tí tư duy biết được qua cách
giải một cái gì đó Còn nếu không thì ông
ôm xử vào chity rồi bảo sử kiểu sửa lại
đoạn code này tôi cho nó tối ưu hơn đấy
và và hỏi lại nó là mày áp dụng thuật
toán gì đấy đấy đấy một cách còn về o op
để mà ông nói op ấy Thực ra đến chính
tôi Giờ tôi còn chưa kiểu áp dụng được
nhiều và tôi tính ra ấy ông nên ôn về
cái đấy vì tôi hỏi chity rồi CHT nó trả
lời op rất yếu luôn kiểu Ừ nó chỉ biết
lý thyc suông ấy Nó khó mà kiểu gợi ý
cho mình chính xác được vân vân mình
phải áp dụng rất nhiều đấy thì rõ ràng
là cái thuật toán là cái thứ nó áp dụng
mình đỉnh hơn thì mình mình nhờ nó trợ
giúp được rồi còn cái mà nó khó trợ giúp
mình thì mình phải tự học thế thôi anh
ơi cho em hỏi cây nào mình dùng cte Câ
dùng view Ừ hình như là em đang nói về
trong trường hợp liên quan về SQL Server
đúng không Thực ra là anh đ làm chưa đi
làm thực
tế động vào equ server này khó trả lời
cho em được câu này
rồi Anh nghĩ là Ờ em cứ đấy copy câu SQL
ra xong rồi lại hỏi ch GT tiếp à thực ra
gần đây có gini ngon hơn nhưng mà ngon
hơn về code thôi tôi chưa biết về cách
trả lời và cách giải thích của nó sẽ như
nào chưa thử Ừ để để khi nào tôi thử nhỉ
tôi mới thử C pilot này C pilot này khá
là tệ khá là tệ so chity Chắc là ch tôi
tôi trả tiền còn thằng này nó miễn phí Ừ
ch để tôi sẽ thử theo thử Germany với
vài cái thằng mới
cách thiết kế database được không ạ Thực
ra thì dự án này Hôm qua tôi vừa đi Ngồi
nói chuyện với bạn kiểu cái người bạn mà
tôi làm cái dự án này hộ cho ấy làm thì
thế là bạn đấy đấ nh là bạn đấy là bạn
không biết gì về công nghệ nên bạn ấy
cũng ok thoải mái Dạ cũng được nhưng mà
tôi biết được là là nói chung là mình
cũng đang kiểu chia sẻ code của cái
trang web bạn bên bạn đấy bởi vì làm này
làm mất phí mà nên là nên là kiểu đang
chia sẻ Thực ra nó có thể có thể Nhị cảm
một cái gì đó và liên quan đến database
nữa còn nhạy cảm hơn đương nhiên là bây
giờ database hoàn toàn là đang là gọi
nhỉ giữ liệu Ảo chẳng có dữ liệu thật gì
cả nhưng là chỉ là nó là một cái thứ r
nhạy cảm nên là chắc là khó mà chia sẻ
được thỉ thoảng mấy ông sẽ thấy thấy tôi
có kiểu code kiểu gì chẳng biết qua một
tí database nhưng mà tôi khó mà kiểu
công khai một cách database thẳng thừng
được cách chi tiết
được còn về cách mà bạn muốn hỏi tôi
kiểu thiết kế database cho một cái gì gì
đó ấy thì tôi hoàn toàn trợ giúp được
các bạn giống như là nhiều bạn hỏi qua
discord ấy tôi vẫn sẵn sàng trợ giúp
ok
Em muốn hỏi mình nên code DB trong
folder database của larel hay nên code
DB bên
m à Cái này hồi trước tôi cũng từng từng
kiểu thắc mắc kiểu thế n Nói chung là
kiểu Ý em là kiểu tạm file migration
hoặc là hay là tự code h kiểu nói chung
Build sẵn bằng những cái kiểu tool hoặc
là viết sẵn code eql để chạy đúng
không Thì lời khuyên ở đây không phải tự
nhiên nó sinh ra cái thằng m nó ngoài
việc là để tự động tạo ra database các
th thứ về sau mình sẽ còn quản
lý quản lý database dựa trên cái mấy cái
file migration đấy nữa là thỉnh thoảng
mình sẽ r lại kiểu mình sẽ kiểu khôi
phục lại một vài cái nên là mình sẽ phải
cần có up và down nó khá hợp lý khá đúng
nữa vân vân Nói chung là về
sau cái làm việc với lel nhiều đủ để tôi
đánh giá đó là mình nên làm mọi thứ quản
lý trong code n Thay vì mình quản lý
logic hay một cái gì đó ở ngoài code
backend ví dụ là xử lý logic ở trong
database hay là xử lý logic ở ngoài
fance là không nên nên làm mọi thứ ở
back end để mình về sau mình dễ sửa mình
dễ kiểm soát ở trong đấy mình còn biết
được lý do kiểu mình còn dễ tra được lỗi
các th thứ đúng không tra được vấn
đề
sin học sinh của một trường mà chưa biết
phân tích như thế nào anh tư vấn giúp em
thiết kế database với ạ Ờ em lên
discorde hỏi câu này nhá Thực ra là anh
Chính anh hồi trước từng làm cái trang
web quản lý cho nhà trường nó bao gồm
rất rất nhiều tính năng luôn bởi vì nó
đem vào ứng dụng làm luôn mà và để tiện
cho giáo vụ nữa Nên hồi đấy là kiểu cái
gì mà giáo vụ kiểu nói chung là muốn làm
là coi như là hồi đy anh phải làm rất
nhiều bao gồm việc là từ việc quản lý x
việc chăm sóc sinh viên cho việc in điểm
tổng kết vân vân đế thậm chí là đến cả
việc điểm danh tính lương cho giáo viên
rất nhiều à đương nhiên là cái phần của
em thì chắc là nó không đủ phức tạp lên
Thế nên là anh nghĩ hoàn toàn Anh thể
trợ giúp được em và đặc biệt là
kiểu đ đặc biệt là kiểu em cũng phải ghi
mô tả qua là là em muốn làm những tính
năng nào nữa để mà từ đấy mà phân tích
được database chứ không thể nói một câu
chung chung kiểu bởi vì đề bài nghe thế
nó rộng
biết về HTML đúng nếu mà nếu mà hoàn
toàn xử lý logic mà không không phải về
mỗi logic đâu ý tôi vừa nói không phải
về mỗi vụ vai đ nhá mà rất nhiều logic
là kểu nó chỉ đơn giản là về lỗi lỗi
logic thôi ví dụ hồi trước tôi từng làm
cái vụ nhá Làm tròn số thôi rất đơn giản
làm tròn số thôi đấy Ở fan lại làm tròn
số thêm một phát nữa cuối cùng bị lệch
số S lệch số xong rồi Kiểu hồi đấy ngồi
kiểu Hồi đấy ngồi kiểu khách kiện ấy
kiểu tưởng là mình ăn gian tiền của nó
ấy đấy Xong rồi Kiểu mình tìm mãi không
thấy không không tìm ra được nguyên nhân
hóa ra là fen còn sửa thêm một phát nữa
đấy Kiểu thế đấy một cái Điển hình thôi
đó là
mình theo mình quan điểm thì fan end bản
chất là nó vẫn mang thên hướng là kiểu
in ra những cái mà backend trả về chứ
không phải
là là backend xử lý một kiểu fan lại xử
lý kiểu nữa Ui thế là không ổn đúng
không còn về vụ vies thì thực ra là vies
nếu mà chuẩn nhất ấy thì Phả ves cả ở
frontend và ở back end Tại sao v đ fan
bởi vì V fen chỉ đơn giản là để cho nó
thông báo phản hối nhanh cho người dùng
và không làm cho quá tải cho việc Bá en
phải xử lý thêm bước nữa kiểu vì rõ ràng
là có nhiều đơ à Nhiều form là kiểu bắt
buộc phải điền đấy một điển hình đấy thì
rõ ràng là cái trình duyệt nó nên phản
hồi ngay lập tức là kiểu mày cần điền
cái này th thay vì kiểu backend trả về
cái gì đó lại mất công xử lý đúng
không anh nói qua về dependc injection
được không gần đây tôi cũng phải tìm
hiểu về cái đấy mà khi mà tôi đang tìm
hiểu tức là tôi chưa dành nó nên tôi
không biết trả lời ông như nào Nhưng mà
thật sự thì Ờ hôm trước tôi mới đọc cái
bài của anh Huy chia sẻ trên
larel larel Việt
À
đây là qua về khá là
nha Nhưng mà đương nhiên là tôi không
Nhớ tôi
những cái bài này cô đọng theo kiểu là
mình phải đọc ngẫm nhiều chứ đọc lúc đầu
thấy hay xong rồi mình không áp dụng là
mình dễ quên bây giờ Thậm chí bây giờ
tôi bắt đầu quên dần rồi à gì nhỉ cái
nhưng mà với tôi quan điểm
nhá đó là ít nhất ít nhất là mình đang
có dùng Framework rồi nó cũng tương đối
là mvc và một tí op
rồi thì ừ tính ra nếu mà mình chỉ chỉ
dừng lại ở đấy là mvc và oop thuần mình
vẫn làm được rất nhiều thứ
nó n nạ giống như kiểu WordPress hay là
hay là kiểu magento ấy nếu mà vào đọc
codt lõi của nó thực cạm đau đầu đấy đấy
thì bản bản chất là mình không cần phải
nghĩ quá phức tạp để giải quyết một cái
gì đó mà mình cứ làm mọi thứ đơn giản
à một một cái trang web đơn giản một
trang web tin tức một trang web bán hàng
có ít tính năng tự nhiên mình ngồi vẽ
kiểu theo kiểu op S Design design button
quá ghê gớm thc cả nó cũng chính mình lạ
khiến cho nó hôm đấy có nói về cái Kid à
À không không không không phải bài lỗi
tôi có một bài tôi đọc cũng trên lareal
Việt Nam nói về cái đề tài là Kid các
bạn biết Kid không nhỉ Kid là là kiểu
Nếu tắt nó sẽ là hôn đúng không pe đâ
đợi Đợi tí Đợi
K là keep
it simple
stupid đấy
nghĩa nghĩa là kiểu hãy khến nó kh làm
cho mọi thứ đơn giản thôi đừng có kiểu
phức tạp nó lên
đấy nghĩa là có rất nhiều lúc mình cứ
kiểu đặc biệt là mình còn mới nữa mình
là mình có thể Junior tôi thì cảm thấy
gần đây tôi bắt đầu bập bõm lên xio hồi
trước tôi cứ tự tin là kiểu gi bây giờ
bài toán nào Bây giờ mình chẳng làm được
Kiểu thế tôi l nghĩ tôi xo từ hồi trước
từ lâu rồi nhưng gần đây tôi mới cảm
thấy là kiểu tôi mới bõm lên xo thật sự
như thế thế thế đầu tiên khái niệm Tại
sao phải như thế nhiều người th Đánh giá
qua năm kinh nghiệm hoặc là làm được
việc đúng không Thế tôi không phải như
thế thế tôi là kiểu ở đây tôi mới bắt
đầu thấy kiểu suy nghĩ kiểu nó gọi là
mình bắt đầu chậm lại đấy Kiểu thế chiếm
nghiệm hơn chậm lại không phải là kiểu
ngựa non háo đá Hồi trước nữa nó n ná
giống như nếu mà chơi game à Mấy ông sẽ
thấy là kiểu tầm ngưỡng cứ cho sho đối
với tôi nhá đ cứ cho ll đi nếu mếu bị
chơi ll thì nó sẽ phải
xio Chắc là phải rank kiểu kiểu kim
cương đổ lên kim cương ca thủ thách đấu
gì đó thì lúc đấy thì khi mà gặp địch
gặp địch kiểu là địch trông có vẻ dễ ăn
thì mình không lao vào sấn sổ nữa mình
phải tính trước rất nhiều cái xong rồi
Nếu mà địch mà ném skin kiểu tung chiêu
ra thì m bắt đầu né chứ không phải hơi
tí mình cứ né
trước mình mới bắt đầu bật flash chạy
đúng không có trước cứ thấy địch cái bật
flash chạy luôn đấy Đấy là cách kiểu của
người chơ Chải
Đấy sinio Như thế là chỉ là mình có
những cái mà mình sẽ kiểu cần phải tìm ỉ
cẩn thận có những cái đơn giản thôi Mình
cứ làm nó đơn giản chạy được là được
không cần phải nhất thiết cầu kỳ Nói
chung là cái nào biết cân nhắc hơn mọi
cái và nghĩ kỹ trước khi code Bây giờ
tôi cả ngày tôi ngồi bàn với sếp xong
rồi tôi mới bắt đầu ngồi cốt đấy Hồi
trước thì tôi cứ cốt kiểu cốt nhanh cốt
rất láo cốt rất ẩu một ngày khoe làm
được bao nhiêu t các thứ th vừa nãy vừa
khoe làm n t xong nhỉ Ô quên mất đấy th
thế tôi bả tôi V mới chỉ chập chững lên
coo thôi Tôi Vẫn ham Vẫn kiểu làm mọi
thứ nhanh nĩ là bất ẩu hơn rồi
xong giờ nó tự chuyển đổi sang SQL và N
SQL không còn dùng lệnh trực tiếp nữa
Đúng lâu rồi chứ hồi tôi dùng Framework
larel lâu rồi nó đã tự động ông chỉ cần
kiểu gọi đến đúng khai báo connection
xong rồi khai báo driver là nó tự động
kiểu ra những cái cấu truy vấn cho mình
mình không cần phải lo về cấu truy vấn
về sau mình dùng song song nhiều
database nhiều connection nhiều driver
Mình chỉ cần thay đổi config nó là
được mình tôi nghĩ phải biết luồng
chạy
làm giống web udi liệu ổn
không Cái này hôm trước anh trả lời
rồi Em đang học công nghệ ông tin em
thấy thị trường dạo này khó khăn với
sinh viên ra trường đâu phải Dạo này đâu
Lúc nào chẳng khó khăn ngày nào chẳng
khó tôi thường khuyên mấy cái này nhiều
nữa dễ không bao giờ đế lượt mình đúng
không cái gì cũng khó cả nên là phải
chấp nhận quen việc khó ông nào chấp
nhận sớm ông nào nhận thức được cái việc
đấy sớm là kiểu nó hiển nhiên ấy đó điều
hiển nhiên là sẽ khó ấy hiển nhiên là sẽ
vất vả
ấy đấy chỉ cảm thấy là mình có dám đánh
đổi ok ông biết được là ông biết được là
kiểu nó sẽ khó Thế ông có dám đánh đổi
thời gian công sức hay mọi thứ không Ông
cảm thấy thực sự là ok Nó là con đường
kiểu con đường duy nhất của ông hay
không đấy ông cắm đâu vàoo đi kiểu gì nó
cũng sẽ ra được một cái gì đó Có thể là
không như người ta theo kiểu là con nhà
người ta theo kiểu là cậu Em sinh năm 96
kiếm được bao nhiêu bao nhiêu không được
như thế
Tôi nghĩ là kiểu gị sẽ ra được gì đó
thôi Có cách nào dùng audio chuyển sang
văn bản không ạ Ừ telam hình như có
phải
larel l weare tôi tôi chưa Dùng hồi
trước tôi định dùng đấy nhưng mà C Tôi
không có thời gian gì mà kiểu m mom cái
đấy nếu bây giờ tôi dùng thì chắc tôi
dùng tôi vẫn Thiên hướng là dùng hẳn một
frw ja Script hơn là dùng
liveware vậ thì Hôm nay tôi định tâm sự
Cái này nếu mà các bạn chưa biết thì
nick Facebook của tôi bay rồi không phải
bay mà chính xác là ờ Ở đây có lần hai
Tức là sao lần đầu tiên cách đây cũng
lâu rồi đấy xem
2019 bây giờ là
ồ hơn 5 năm một tí
đấy Hồi trước thì tôi đã tương tự hào vỗ
ngực là kiểu chia sẻ cái bài về bảo mật
bảo mật một tí về Facebook đấy ciểu là
cài đặt các thứ thứ như nào cho nó ổn ơn
tí so về sau cái đợt này này thì đăng
đăng nhập và đăng nhập Facebook ở ngoài
quán nét và hình như ở đây gắn K lock
Hồi đấy Hơi bị lười Hồi đấy Hơi bị lười
điểm là lỡ bấm nút là TH thường tôi có
mở kiểu bảo mật hai lớp ấy nhưng mà tôi
bấm nút là kiểu lưu lại dính duyệt để mà
kiểu lần sau đăng nhập vào không cần
phải điên nữa và tôi lúc đấy tôi mới
nhận ra lúc kiểu có mấy lần sau đăng
nhập thì thấy là Uầy chỗ này kiểu Có vẻ
mọi máy đều kết nối chung một con server
và cùng chung kiểu kiểu một cục Model
nên thành ra là kiểu khi mà chỉ cần đăng
nhập vào một máy thôi xong rồi ấn lưu
trình duyệt đấy thì ông đang nhập sang
máy khác ông cũng không phải hỏi cái bảo
mật hai lớp đấy Thế nếu mà giả sử mà Đấy
lần đấy chắc là tôi nghĩ đấy do có thể
tôi bị hack có thể thế thôi Không biết
được Thì đại khái là
tôi về nhà thì thấy bị đổi Email của
Nick đấy số điện thoại thì vẫn còn nhưng
mà nó có vẻ nó ngồi spam cho cái số điện
thoại để cho số điện thoại không gửi
được cái mã code nữa đấy Nên là hồi hồi
đấy kiểu may mà mà cái cái ứng vẫn còn
đăng nhập trên ứng dụng Facebook Chẳng
qua là bị đăng xất băng ra thôi nhưng mà
vẫn có thể bấm vào cái hình ảnh trang cá
nhân để mà có thể đăng nhập vào được chứ
không cần phải xin mật khẩu đấy thì nó
yêu cầu là kiểu nhập mã xác thực thì cái
mã xác thực này là phải gửi về số điện
thoại chứ không còn là mã sơ thực kiểu
bằng App bình thường của oat nữa
cách nào vì mã không về đấy dùng thử
tính năng kiểu Ừ nhờ 3 trong năm người
bạn mình tin cậy Hồi đấy có cái tính
năng
người đấy Gửi tôi cái đoạn Mã để mà mình
nhập vào vẫn không lấy được bởi vì hình
như là cái hồi đấy là Facebook nó còn bị
à Kiểu hồi đấy Facebook bị cái lỗi về
cái vụ đấy nế thành ra là năm bạn bè
đang tinh cậy K chẳng đáng tinh cậy tiệ
nào đấy Lúc đấy thì bắt đầu phải cầu cứu
đủ kiểu xong rồi cuối cùng thì phải đi
nhờ chick cer đi tìm các nhóm chick cer
lúc đy rất là ngại bởi vì có nhiều anh
em khuyên đó là bây giờ nếu mà chị cơ mà
lấy lại để cho mình nick đồng nghĩ việc
là nếu mình để lộ thông tin để mà chị cơ
lấy hộ lại mình nick ấ về sau chị cơ
hoàn toàn th dùng mấy cái thông tin đấy
để lấy chiếm quyền nick của mình đấy Nên
hồi đệ rất là rén rồi rồi Kiểu gì Tìm
rồi cùng để ý được một ông cũng ở trong
nhóm J2 đấy xong nhắn tin riêng rồi rồi
bảo là nhớ hỗ trợ cho mình chấp nhận mất
một tí phí à Miễn sao là họ chỉ mình
cách chứ không phải là mình đưa hết
thông tin ch họ đấy Xong rồi ông đấy mất
5 lít để cho một cái bài học đó là hồi
đấy có cái vụ đấy tôi Không cái này thay
đổi liên tục nhá nên là tôi khuyên mấy
ông bây giờ không có nghĩa là mấy ông
bây giờ mà gặp cái lỗi đấy mấy ông ngồi
làm giống tôi là coi như là nó được
không nhá Nó nhảy sang cái lỗi khác mà
có vấn đề gì đó thì thì CN rách việc hơn
đấy Nói chung là ông ấy cuối cùng tôi
trả ông ấy 5 lít rồi ông ấy bảo tôi là
ông chỉ còn ngồi spam sai cái mã xác
thực 10 lần th nó sẽ đá check po đá đá
lỗi sang check bằng cái khác đấy rồi tôi
thử vài cùng được check sang cái khác
thì mình chải được Ok mình lấy lại được
nick đấy còn bây giờ Bây giờ thì hôm qua
tôi vừa chạy cái
tool nên là xong rồi tối ngày hôm qua
thằng Facebook khóa vì mình ngh ngờ mình
bị kiểu chiếm Kim Cản Sát hay gì gì đó
có những hành vi lạ thường gì gì đó nó
khóa s nick ạ Chứ không phải bị ông
hacker nó hack cả nó khóa nick à khóa
nick ở đây nó nghi ngờ xong rồi nó còn
báo là gì ạ Bạn cần đăng nhập bằng thiết
bị cũ để mà lấy lại nick
đấy nhưng mà cuối cùng thì tôi đăng nhập
bằng nick cũ vẫn có được đâu rất là buồn
cười nói chung là kiểu tôi từ hôm qua
giờ chỉ ngồi suy nghĩ kiểu thừ nó bị còn
cười rồi đợi tí tôi đăng nhập lại cho
mấy ông
gửi tin nhắn về số điện thoại
khẩu Facebook em hack thủ được không ha
đ he nó gì
956 Cái này là trường hợp cây 956 đấy
Yeah mình đã bị khóa tài khoản Đây là
kiểu dạng 956 dạng kết Sắt đấy theo như
chi cer thường nay nói là như thế
tôi nên dùng kiểu điện thoại hoặc là máy
tính Đăng từng đăng
anh à th không sao C có khi mật khẩu Đâu
vừa rồi chỉ nhập mã OTP
người có người hôm qua
nhờ thì bảo là đợi hai tuần à Hay mộ
tháng gì đó nó sẽ nhả ra không biết thực
sự có nhả
không nhưng mà cũng không cũng hơi ngại
khi mà có thể đưa
các chck cer
kiểu lấy lại được nick không biết lấy
lại được không thc ra tôi nói chung là
phí phí thì cũng không biết được đôi khi
là người ta sẽ đánh giá nhìn nick mình
trông có vẻ gì thí đó thì đói phí cao
nhưng mà cho tôi không biết
được
bị nhược điểm mình hơi chủ quan chủ quan
ở đây là mình tích hợp kết nối khá nhiều
à Facebook với khá nhiều tài khoản khác
đấy có là một cái mà tôi khuyên mấy ông
là kiểu không nên lưu đầu tiên là không
nên lưu mọi thứ kiểu trên Facebook ví dụ
Giả sử Giả
sử mẹ tôi chẳng hạn hoặc là vài người
nữa Hồi trước đó là kiểu
à Coi Facebook là kiểu cái nhật ký để
chia sẻ kỷ niệm đăng hết mọi thứ lên đấy
xong rồi xóa hết mọi thứ ảnh trong điện
thoại để cho nó gọi là à Đỡ tốn bộ nhớ
đúng không coi như Facebook là một cái
bụ là cái máy kiểu cái ổ nhớ của mình
đấy sau Facebook mà có vấn đề gì đó thì
thôi hiểu ý tôi không
chích gì đó để phá thế Vừa rồi tôi bị
khóa vì tôi nghịch tool chứ không phải
là vì à bảo mật gì
độ cá nhân Nói chung là ngoài việc nó là
mối mối liên hệ khá nhiều quá à kiểu
quan hệ rộng đúng không kiểu kết nối
nhiều mối quan hệ qua Facebook này Đấy
sau Kết nối Facebook với khá nhiều tài
khoản khác nữa lúc ấy lúc ấy Tôi mới
nhận ra là kiểu
à dạng như nà nhỉ Có vài thằng kiểu nó
nó kết nối qua Facebook chứ không hề lưu
không hề lưu kiểu email của mình từ
Facebook Tức là sao nghĩa là ví dụ là
tôi đăng
nhập tôi đăng ký đăng ký cái trang web
đấy bằng tài khoản Facebook đúng không
nó chỉ lưu Mỗi tài khoản Facebook của
tôi thôi chứ không lưu cái email nghĩa
email để vào thì không được nó sẽ coi
như một tài khoản mới C thế nên là hơi
khó để mà khôi phục cái tài khoản Nếu mà
giả sử Facebook có vấn
leader Họ hỏi s Project mình làm không
Anh có chứ có một cái đấy để mà hỏi mấy
ông các thứ V kiến thức
khoản các thử thử không nên chủ quan các
thử các thử Thực ra là
tôi và nó cứ coi như là bây giờ trước
mắt thì mình đang trong thời gian chờ
đợi nên là mình đang không dùng mạng xã
hội Facebook cũng đỡ đi một tí ch bớ t
xích Chắc
thế Nói chung là mình cũng gọi nhở tôi
bắt đầu nhận ra có nhiều người lâ key à
Đang ít mọi thứ trên đấy và không bị gò
bó không bị kiểu biến nó thành một cái
điểm yếu Ý ông hiểu tôi không kiểu mình
bị Phụ thuộc nó quá thành ra nó sẽ một
điểm yếu gì đó của mình mình Mất nó mình
cảm thấy mất mát một cái gì đó lớn
đấy có nhiều người tôi quen là kiểu hoàn
toàn họ coi việc cái Facebook nó chỉ là
một cái công cụ đúng nghĩa giải trí thôi
rất là bình thường
họ không dùng cái này thì dùng cái khác
không quan trọng họ có đăng mọi thứ lên
đấy đấy có Nhưng mà như nào thường là
mấy người đấy là dùng Facebook và chỉ
đơn giản bởi vì muốn kết nối kiểu Ừ thì
người thân của họ dùng Facebook nên
thành ng họ dùng đấy chứ còn không thì
tao dùng cái khác cũng được an kểu thế
nó n ná giống như là đối với tôi bây giờ
chắc là phải Zalo à Zalo nó đúng kiểu
như thế kểu người khác dùng mình dùng
mình không quan trọng nó lắm Mình chẳng
bao giờ đăng mọi thứ lên đấy đấy Kiểu
thế
trong tối nay chắc là không Tối nay kiểu
Định hôm nay hơi tấm trạm một tí không
quý định dậy tâm trạng là cũng choáng
đầu nữa Ngồi làm xong choáng Chiều nay
ngồi nát xong đầu kia xong choáng
thôi toàn bộ Meta sập là đáng quan ngại
đấy anh còn anh còn tiếc Rất nhiều cái
trên đó rất nhiều bạn xinh xinh mình
theo dõi trên đấy đương nhiên
là là mấy bạn đấy Kiểu gì chẳng chuyển
chỗ C thử nếu mà cái này sập thì thì kể
cả Giả sử Tôi đã nghĩ Trường hợp xấu
nhất rồi Giả sử Facebook mình có vấn đề
gì đó thì thôi mình lại đi theo dõi một
đ mới làm lại từ
được gái đâu mà dạy tôi chỉ dạy được cái
kiểu tôi chỉ đưa những lời khuyên là
không ba giờ nên làm từ những cái bài
học xương máu của tôi với a đó là thứ
nhất không bao giờ khái niệm tán được
gãi mình chưa giai đoạn kiểu Bad Boy có
thể mà biến không thành có chỉn giản là
ngay từ lúc đầu Họ mở cửa xanh cho mình
thế thôi
vài lúc có nhớ lại thì đúng là đôi khi
hồi trước họ mực xanh cho mình mình còn
mình không nhận ra mình còn gàn đi cơ
xã hội đấy à Không Bây giờ nó đang tập
trung hết được một chỗ rõ ràng mình nên
chỉ lên một chỗ thôi Còn khi bây giờ mà
vỡ cái coi như là các bạn đấy mỗi người
muốn ngả Và thậm chí là gọi nhở nhều
người không đăng nữa các
thứ đấy Họ quen đăng hết ở một chỗ kiểu
coi như một nơi thì lưu rồi X Tự nhiên
bây giờ mà mà nó có vấn đề đúng không họ
sẽ mất niềm tin và mọi mạng xã hội rồi
họ không năng nữa họ không Đang nhiều
tiêu cực
đại học và kỹ
năng thì trong trường hợp em làm được
cái n chỉ bằng
Ừ tập đoàn lớn thì nó hơi khó đấy Nên
là tùy
Nói chung là theo tôi thì nó còn liên
quan Ừ chắc là đôi khi phải nhờ mối quan
hệ tí Bởi vì ông về cơ bản ông đang ông
đang kiểu dạng là không đặt cái yêu cầu
cơ
này
tuổi trẻ nên đầu tư tôi có ghi cái này
Hôm trước Ừ
không hôm A ừ không biết bây giờ mình
nói mấy cái này ra có tính ở lùa gà
không n Tôi không nói cụ thể một cái gì
đó chắc là không phải lùa gà đâu ạ
Ờ tôi rất đầu tiên là nhưng mà tôi vẫn
nhấn mạnh à Tôi rất sợ việc kiểu về sao
kiểu bị dính có nhiều người nổi tiếng gì
gì đó họ nổi rồi nó nhá nhá Còn mình
chưa là cái gì cả nhá n nói là họ nổi
rồi họ chỉ cần nói vu v một cái gì đó
Rồi rồi về sau bị gàn MC lùa gà luôn n
Tôi rất sợ vụ này nhưng mà tôi sã chia
sẻ thôi tôi vẫn chia sẻ cái cá nhân của
bản thân mình tô chẳng khuyên mấy ông
làm gì cả đấy Đó là kiểu Gần đây tôi nói
chung là ngay từ hôm qua thôi ngay từ
hôm qua lần đầu tiên
tôi đi đầu tư đó là tôi đi mua vàng đấy
không biết mấy ông đã có mấy chỉ hay
thậm chí là có kiểu mấy thỏi ở nhà rồi
Hôm qua tôi bắt đầu đi đầu tư kiểu Hồi
trước tôi từng nghĩ rằng là mình sẽ
không Mình sẽ rất hạn chế liên quan đến
đầu tư liên quan tiền bạc gì gì
đó nhưng mà tôi Tôi cảm thấy là bây giờ
Nói chung là bây giờ khi mà làm được rồi
nó cũng gọi là có một tí dư giả hơn có
tiền thì bây giờ khi gửi s tiết kiệm thì
cái lãi suất Nó không cao cái việc là
không gửi sổ đương nhiên là đấy tiền
chết rồi đúng không Đấy tiền cà ngày cà
mất giá vân vân nên là tôi nghĩ là tôi
phải đi đầu tư cái khác đầu tư thêm một
cái mảng ở đó Đương nhiên là phần lớn
tôi vẫn để trong số tiết kiệm nhưng mà
một phần ít ra kiểu thỉnh thoảng có
ấy đấy thì tôi sẽ bởi vì gửi sổ tiết
kiệm thì đươ nhiên gửi sổ tiết kiệm theo
định kỳ ví dụ là 6 tháng hay 1 năm đúng
không Thì tự nhiên mỗi tháng ấy dư dư
một tí ra thì cái số tiền đấy để đâu đấy
lại gử tạo thêm cái sổ nữa đấy thế nên
là tôi đầu tư sang một vài cái khác
giống như là tôi mua chính trỉ quỹ hay
là vàng gì gì hôm qua lần đầu tiên đi
mua vàng cái việc tự nhiên mọi khi tôi
đi mua cái chứng trừ quỹ cơ như là hôm
qua quyết định đi mua vàng Bởi vì tôi
tôi kể mấy ông chưa nhỉ Đó là
tôi tích được tiền mừng tuổi hơn 2 năm
rồi à tôi kiểu Tôi không muốn bóp cái lì
xì mừng tuổi ra vì nó kiểu nó kiểu Tôi
cảm thấy nó Lucky Money tiền may mắn ấ
thì nói chung là mình không nên tiêu nó
cũng Thậm chí không nên bóc nó ra mình
giữ may nhưng
mà nhưng mà gọi nh thì thì để đấy tôi
định để đấy Thật Sau Cuối cùng thì cảm
thấy là cứ để đấy thì tiền cà cà mất giá
thì đấy Tiến chết rồi đúng không Thế là
thôi
Phải bây giờ đi mua vào coi như là một
cái gì đó cũng may mắn và về sau còn để
đấy mà còn lấy vợ tiền Nói chung là tiền
mừng tuổi đấy tôi định để dành đến khi
mà lấy vợ thì tôi bóc thật nó giống như
kiểu đi gọ gì nhở
à đếm tiền vào đêm tân hôn ấy đúng không
đêm tân hôn đúng nhỉ Ừ đúng đêm tân hôn
đấy Thế Gi Mình đếm cả Tiến tiết kiệm
nữa định là như
không nhiều đâu nã Cả một phần là tôi
toàn đi lì xì người khác tôi toàn đi lì
xì cả người lớn nên thnh họ cũng phải
miễn cưỡng lì xì lại tôi ấ nó không
nhiều lắm đâu so với số tiền tôi bỏ ra
nó chảng là cái gì cả Nói chung
là
vàng cũng là một cái trải nghiệm gì gì
đó Lúc đầu Lúc đầu vào
kiểu lúc đầu vào người ta cứ tưởng mình
sộp lắm C mình đi mua nửa
với anh Ừ anh cũng đang cân nhắc kiểu có
thời gian thì anh sẽ kiểu đăng bài lên
len đây anh đang nghĩ văn nữa mà nói
chung là phải dư giản thời gian lơn Tí
nói chung là anh sẽ định đăng bài và một
ngày đấy Anh sẽ ngồi theo dõi bài đang
được đấy Ừ nhở hai trong lúc mình đang
bị mất Face mình có thời gian rành để mà
lên lon lướt nhỉ Ừ ông nói một ý hay
được để mai bận rồi Để để tôi xem sắp
xếp một ngày thôi ngồi đăng bài tới sớm
xu tôi sẽ ngồi lọc rồi ngồi làm được
không ạ Ok
Văn Kiểu gì nh
Văn nó bị cứng ngắc
nhầm
rồi Thế ông lại quá nhầm
rồi Nói chung là đúng rồi Bây giờ tôi dư
giá hơn một tí bởi
vì Nói chung là bởi vì đi đi làm cũng
rất là may mắn đi làm cũng đủ ăn đủ tiêu
các thứ thứ thí nh là trong ngành này và
mình đang có một mình thôi mà nên thành
ra kểu chẳng dư giả thằng con trai thì
nó t sống tương đối dễ mà đúng
không Bây giờ ông làm lương một tháng
tôi nghĩ là tầm 8 triệu cũng gọi dơ Giảm
một tí Nếu ông sống một
cho em một số câu hỏi được không
ạ Cái này anh nghĩ là em hỏi trên mạng
nó có nhiều hơn ấy nó cũng chỉ chung
chung mấy cái câu các thứ cơ bản lắm
fresser tự ra người ta không có gì hỏi
nhiều đâu yên tâm đi Cứ tự tin lên em
thoải mái lên em quan trọng nhất là
người ta tuyển mình vì thái độ là nhiều
đấy chứ còn về thực lực thì mấy ông đều
sàn sàn bằng nhau có gì mấy
luôn ấy đấy đại khái thì OK tôi vừa nói
về đầu tư đấy về kinh tế thì đầu tư tiếp
V về gì có nhiều người bảo đầu tư ở đây
đầu tư luôn cả về chuyện cảm luôn nghĩa
là kiếm kiếm Yu đi không Lại Mất lại mất
vào tay ông khác người khác nó là giống
như kiểu Hồi trước có câu đó
là gái xinh như tên miền đẹp thường là
có à thường là đã có sở hữu rồi Hoặc là
rất đắt
đấy
Ờ nói chung là nếu có thể thì mấy ông
đầu tư về khoản đấy nữa t tứ là chuyện
tình cảm các thứ thứ đầu tư vào à đây
chuyện tình cảm phát triển bản thân
Ừ tiếp theo là như tôi thường hay khuyên
mấy ông đó là phải thử phải trải nghiệm
các thứ thứ đầu tư vào
à bao gồm cả về gọ gọi như nào nhỉ vừa
rồi thường anh nói là kiểu đầu tư
Bitcoin hay đầu tư và vàng hay gì gì đó
các thứ kia nó có thể mất đi giá trị
theo thời gian vì có thể có lúc lên có
lúc xuống thì theo tôi cái đầu tư mà
đáng giá nhất thì đương nhiên là đầu tư
là việc học hành đầu tư vào mình bỏ tiền
ra để mà
mình mua được một cái kiến thức gì đó
đúng không Thì tôi thấy là ổn nhất đầu
tư vào chính trí tuệ trí o mình bởi vì
từ đấy mình sẽ có thể kiếm được nhiều
hơn
trọng không ngạ Nếu đấy là thứ duy nhất
ông có thể khoe được thì đúng là nó quan
trọng thật còn nếu mà ông có thể khoe
được rất nhiều cái khác thì nó sẽ chỉ là
một trong những cái cái để ống khoay đâu
mà đúng không
tôi ghi cái này nhưng mà tôi quên tôi
cảm thấy là bây giờ thấy nó cũng bình
thường để mà không nói là chắc bỏ qua đi
Nói chung là hồi đấy nghĩ nó ngầu nghĩ
nó hay tôi lưu lại thôi đậ t giữ một ler
siêu cấp Vi Pro và 10 ông sinh viên điểm
trung bình và một ông leader điểm trung
bình
đấy đại khái là một ông leader và 10 ông
điểm trung bình và một ông leader điểm
trung bình và 10 ông
này chia Nó kiểu như này đúng
không
đấy
Ừ để xem nhá 10 ông điểm trung bình và
một ông Trung B M leader là người có
quyết định rất nhiều rất rất nhiều bản
thân
đép đép giỏi Mà kiểu cũng thì thường đi
kèm với cái tôi nữa mà nói chuyện mà sếp
của mình mà không nghe sếp mình không
hiểu sếp mình kiểu không duyệt cho làm
thì team đấy nó cũng sẽ tan dã Dần và nó
chẳng đi ở đâu đâu cả nghe thế đủ biết
rồi đúng không ạ một ông leader giỏi ông
đấy có thể dẫn dắt được người không phải
nói dẫn dắt người yếu nhưng mà dẫn dắt
một người gọi là đang tự ti đang đang
Lặc lối có thể đi được con đường đúng
chứ 10 Ông giỏi này mà Mấy ông ấy không
đoàn kết mấy ông ấy thường có cái tôi
nữa và cái mắt xích thường chính là
leader và mắt xích đấy nó còn yếu nó còn
toang nó còn kiểu thiếu hiểu biết hơn cả
một thằng nhân viên ý Uầy lúc đấy Chết
chết chắc luôn úy Kiểu cái dự án nó
chẳng đi về đâu được cả nó sẽ kiểu tan
giã sớm thôi
đấy không biết về cái nào hơn rồi đúng
không nên là đi tìm người xếp giỏi rất
là quan trọng đúng không
ạ em ra trưởng không kiếm được việcc nên
về chỗ người quen vừa làm V phòng vừa
làm D án ty không biết công ty có coi dự
án nh kinh nghiệm
sao đâu Không sao cả khi phỏng vấn quan
trọng là em trả lời được mấy cái em thể
hiện được là mình đã làm được những khá
nhiều thứ K hợp việc là
à là
kiểu thái độ hay các thứ bởi vì em A
từng đi làm rồi cái thái độ
và cái phong thái làm việc của em nó
khác với người chơi làm lắm nên kia yên
tâm không bị đánh giá vào interm đâu Đây
nhá Anh có thể nói lường lel không ạ
start chạy file nào trước rồi đến file
nào đâ cái này em tra l Circle live
Circle nhá thì nó sẽ kiểu hướng dẫn các
thứ xùng chat TVT xong rồi thắc mắc cái
gì hỏi luôn Nó nó sẽ dễ trả lời hơn ấy
Ok mà tâm sự các thứ thứ gần tiếng rồi
tôi thực ra hôm nay đấy quả chắc quả
Facebook mọi thứ nữa đó khiến tôi tâm
trạng năng lượng hơi bị trầm xuống hôm
qua thực ra hôm qua đi học à nh hôm qua
đi dậy cũng bị thế
kiểu tôi Tôi nghĩ là tôi người bị ảnh
hưởng năng lượng ấy kiểu đại khái thì
sinh viên cũng trầm sinh viên cũng buồn
ngủ xong rồi sinh viên cũng chán h vân
vân bởi vì Tôi đang dạy lớp lớp đấy là
họ không hoàn toàn chưa ngành về công
nghệ động tin nên th hơi khó để dạy kiểu
nó nghĩ môn mình không phải là môn thực
sự cần thiết quan trọng ấy lớp đấy là
lớp A lớp đấy là kiểu lớp đấy là về cản
trị kinh doanh cơ đấy thế mà tôi vẫn vẫn
phải dạy lập trình cơ bản tươ nhiên là
tôi vẫn nghĩ là ai cũng nên học lập
trình cho kiểu có tư duy một tí nhưng mà
Ui lớp nhiều gái không á phải nó nói lớp
ấy nhiều trai không mới đúng có một lớp
thì có một ông con trai một một lớp có
ba ông con trai trong 40 bạn nữ đấy đy
Nói chung là
kiểu tôi C phải mua cái loa để ngồi nói
lại được mấy cái mồm nói nhiều tan phét
các thú đủ kiểu luôn
đấy may mắn á Không không may mắn lắm
đâu
ạ em nghe câu cái Khải niệm thực ra là
tôi hơi ngại để mà kiểu đùa đùa các thứ
thứ trên này đùa mấy ông ấy vui đấy
nhưng mà không biết về sao bị cắt ghép
các thứ ghép từ nha về sau nó lại nhạy
cảm về sau tôi còn đi dạy
trường Nếu là lớp của tôi thì thì gọi là
lớp tôi tự mở nó khác Còn đây là của
trường nên thành ra là hơi khó tôi có
được toàn quyền cái gì đâu đâu Cảm thấy
là khi mà đi dạy này đặc biệt là cái môi
trường kiểu trường này thì nó vẫn không
hoản là giống trường đại học mà nó nó là
trường nó nó vẫn là trường nghề thôi vẫn
là kiểu dùng thử công ty tư nhân thì
chắc đúng nghĩa bản chất là là nó sẽ coi
là học sinh là thượng đế V học sinh
khách hàng tiếp theo là cái bộ phận khác
từ giáo vụ hay mọi thứ Nói chung là giáo
viên sẽ vẫn là đáy kiểu ciểu chỉ là
người kiểu được thuê về dạy gần như là
thế nên thành ra kiểu không không có
nhiều quyền đâu không lắm ở trong lớp
thì đương nhiên mình vẫn có quyền quyết
định sinh viên như nào như kia nhưng mà
sinh viên ý kiến hay phụ huynh ý kiến
một phát thì mình phải tự chỉnh lại ngay
Thế mình khó quyền quyết định gì á
Ờ từ bna cũng đúng Nói chung
là tôi cảm thấy tôi phải gồng ấy kiểu
mình cứ phải tỏ ra mình rất đ đang rất
là nhiều năng lượng đang kể rất là tích
cực các thứ thứ để mà cố kiểu lan tỏa cả
năng lượng đấy cho sinh viên còn sinh
viên còn cảm thấy là kiểu có người thấy
thoải mái có người không đúng không
Không Không phải đang tắm đâu ở trướng ở
cái khu tập thể này có thỉnh thoảng ở
tầng trên kiểu nó Nó kiểu Dạ
nh máy bơm nó nhiều nước quá
ấ nó cái cái gọi là nhở Cái bồn à Có gì
nhở đại khái nó bị chán nước ấy nước nó
C chảy
cáo về cái vụ đấy vì thấy máy bơm cứ để
chà nước khá là nhiều th tí tôi tra xem
nên báo cáo như thế
là đại khái
thì việc đi dậy khá là mệt không không
phải nói là việc đi dậy vui được bởi vì
chỉ vui khi mà kiểu gặm gặp kiểu người
kiểu dạng không hẳn học giỏi mà người Ý
ra kiểu cũng có tâm
tí sinh viên cũng kiểu nhiệt tình tí
mình nhiệt tình sinh viên nh cũng nhiệt
tình theo cũng hù theo chứ nếu mà kiểu
mình nhiệt tình sinh viên từ CH chối thì
mình cũng nm đúng không rất mệt mình
kiểu cứ cố kiểu cố kéo nó theo ấy Nhưng
mà nó cứ ghìm mình xuống ấy m Không hiểu
vì tôi không nó đúng kiểu ghìm mình
xuống ấy bởi vì à tôi cứ kiểu nhiệt tình
cá thử năng lượng kiểu hoạ hoạt bát như
thế xong rồi nó kiểu cứ trầm rồi nó
còn không nói đâu nhưng là kiểu nó sẽ có
những hành động kiểu tôi cái thái độ ấy
làm Tôi cảm thấy kiểu
là không hẳn là anh đừng nói nữa đâu mà
nó theo kiểu gì ý theo kiểu là anh không
dậy nữa thì em thấy vui ý đúng kiểu
thế không phải ghét mình dậy đâu nhá mà
chỉ đơn giản là kiểu em đang buồn ngủ ấy
em không muốn học nữa em chỉ muốn ngồi
nghỉ em ch đang muốn ngồi không kiểu
kiểu thế nên thành ra là mình mình cảm
thấy là mình đang mế mới không hiểu ý ý
ý tôi không ạ Đấy người ra mấy bạn ấy tỏ
ra mệt tỏ ra chán nản đang mệt mỏi ấy tự
nhiên là mình l cứ nói thao thao thao ở
đấy đúng không Thì có phải là mình đã
làm phiền họ không đúng không ạ
Đấy như hồi em đi học vậy Thức ra tôi
nghĩ là ai chẳng cũng kiểu như thế từng
một thời tôi thì không như thế tôi luôn
Tô Trọng Giáo viên là không như thế Tôi
chỉ hay nói chuyện riêng thôi nhưng mà
đúng Nói chung là nó khó khó khó khi mà
cả cả lớp mà kiểu nó trầm chầm như
thế mới vài chịu Hồi trước là tôi ở lớp
cũ của tôi tôi cũng thỉnh thoảng mở nhạc
kiểu ra bài tập xong mở nhạc kiểu nhẹ
nhàng cho không ẳn nhẹ nhàng đôi khi
cũng bình thường nói chung là để sinh
viên cảm thấy hay Hưng Thu gì đó Tin tin
tí nhưng mà đấy là sinh viên kiểu cách
tôi ha ba tuổi thôi Còn bây giờ cách tôi
tận 7 tuổi Tôi cảm thấy là bây giờ nhạc
tôi nghe mấy bạn ấy không hề nghe mấy
bạn nghe thệ bả nhạc mà tôi cũng không
thể nghe được thế thành ra là kiểu khó
khó kinh khủng luôn nó n ná thậm chí là
giống như là kiểu bây giờ tôi pha trò
cười các thứ cũng gọi là nó gượng hơn ý
vì ít vì ít bạn Nói chung là có vài bạn
thấy nó sẽ nhạp rồi các thứ kiểu bây giờ
có khi là vài cái joke của mình sẽ bế đ
jog à Mấy biết mấy bạn biết khái niệm D
jog không kiểu câu đùa rất là nhạt dành
của các ông bố ấy đấy tiếng Anh nó dịch
ra
có tự nhiên nhận ra thầy thời gian chôi
nhanh
vậy anh á Ý em là cái này á
chuyển mẫu Ý em là sao chuyên màu như
nào không hiểu
lắm Cái này không phải e key
đâu đó Open key em kiểu khi bấm sang cái
khác là nó tự động đổi đúng không Bởi vì
cái này cái Open key này nó ngon hơn là
nó sẽ hiểu à chạy chạy trên a
đây ghi nhớ theo ứng dụng Tức là chỉ
là là khi em A vào bằng ứng dụng này ví
dụ anh vào trình duyệt ứng dụng này bằng
kiểu anh gõ tiếng Việt Khi anh bấm vàoo
cái khác kiểu
này đang hiểu được là mỗi khi anh mở cái
này thì anh sẽ có bằng tiếng Anh kiểu
thể nó nhớ hộ thế rồii khá
lao không u mấy cái đấy mỗi cái là một
cái luôn ý chắc là chưa
rồi OK tôi đang định off Quên mất Bây
giờ tôi đang à Bây giờ tôi cứ tạm nghỉ
đã nhá Chào mấy ông nhá Có gì anh em hôm
sau tâm sự tiếp ạ à đâu hôm sau phải dậy
này là suly tch nhưng mà su tch này Nói
chung là mình nên dùng cái khác sa tex
này nó hơi hơi cùi để mà mình gọi là một
cái IDE để mà
cút Chào mấy ông nha Bye